that's not the plan
well he did bring up the tattoos I gotta
ask you from somebody who you guys are
high school sweethearts you have two
children together yeah you see Christian
she obviously blows up she's a
personality but she gets
you're okay your son's father tattooed
on her neck so all that happened while I
was pregnant so it kind of to me was
like oh y'all playing with me like and
and your your hormones are going crazy
well that's why I left him to begin with
this because so I was pregnant he's not
coming home he's acting a fool he's not
doing the most so I just left I'm just
going through a lot I took his car I
took his car and I just went to my mom's
what you gonna do now right now I'm
saying this this is and that now what
he's like oh you're crazy whatever we're
gonna have our gender reveal go to the
gender reveal
it's not happening the way it was
supposed to happen like no so look let
me let okay let me chime in no okay so
when she leave me I'm like come back you
know please come back I tell her for
like a week I probably that whole a week
she's been gone I probably hit her like
three times like come on come back you
ain't gotta do this right
so did after a week she like uh-uh I've
been looking at this place I'm gonna go
do this I'm gonna go do that I was that
mad oh my damn all right
so then right that's how I got stuck
with rock cause I'm all right you come
uh you in the game now you're in the
game now [__] come on my [__] left me
you're in the game come on like you're
in you're in I'm a high school I'm a
high school football coach you feel me
yeah that's how I'm out here coaching
Mighty Mites okay family junior [__]
I'm trying to find
okay can we take a shot everyone like
yeah
Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers come on babe
cheers I'm not drinking this oh wait we
got to plug this in here okay you don't
need a drink let me help you out here
all right are we cheers in Cheers Cheers
guys so that's soda by the way guys he
has orange soda in the cup so boom I'm
like all right she left me like chicken
she like on her own [__] I'm gonna get
my own place I wanted to be in my name
I'm going to pay because you was playing
around baby I'll help you you want to
get a place I put it in my name right I
and I did it I pay the bills no [__] I
wanted to be in my name you feel me
mommy got her peace the name is in my
lease I'm like damn you good come on I
did say that she sent me that I did say
that she hit you with the bar I did hit
him with the bar she was like
my name is on the lease mommy got her
piece I was like damn that's okay she
showed you up no but you know what you
you know you know he was like all right
Rock You In the game come on
okay let's be let me let me I have to
take a stance here okay go ahead I'm
somebody who has children
I can listen a pregnant woman yeah no I
know they get they she's good I was four
months pregnant you're going through a
lunatic he saw what I was they were
pregnant no it was four months pregnant
we just found out what it was but listen
I was gonna say Obviously in like I'm a
lunatic you're out doing what you're
doing there's this girl getting
Jonathan's [__] exactly
and she's carrying your child and she
has your other kid and your mom and he
said oh I mean I didn't do that like
he's like the day one
and so for me I'm watching all this and
just from like somebody who is just not
even not even looking at it for somebody
who knows you just looking at her I'm
like okay obviously Christian Rock's
good for business yeah right she's what
it started out as though I never wanted
as far too
she started getting the tattoos on her
own
listen after her first tattoos her first
tattoos I said I don't think you should
be doing this kind of appropriate it
makes you look like me or your intimate
and it's less business
and she just wasn't listening well as I
say did it spiral out of control so much
that you guys were
publicly so associated with with each
other that it kind of was like a forced
because listen when you got like she got
on his blue faces girlfriend well when
y'all came to the studio last time I
interviewed both of you guys
um it was you could cut the tension
between y'all with a knife yeah no it's
kind of like it's kind of like
she got on his blueface's boyfriend
girlfriend I mean you wouldn't have a
boyfriend obviously
Young Person's girlfriend but it's like
she kind of like
used that and then when it wasn't usable
she kind of used that and then when it
wasn't usable she kind of like all right
let me
let me let me go this way you know like
I said I'm not gonna fire you are you
hoping she gets the tattoos removed no I
mean I really don't care for me
personally tattoos are a part of time
history you know trials and tribulations
and I feel like I'm a part of her time
history childhood tribulation so
is there any more business for y'all to
do together
man I'm always interested in business
I'm always open to business but like I
said earlier once you do business
without me it's none of my business and
the relationship aspect of YouTube is
done
I mean she has my if she has my child no
no you guys can have a relationship I
just mean in terms of like you guys
being intimate you guys being you know
any sort of uh
are you are you done clapping Christian
Rock's cheeks at this point in your life
personally
I don't think that
I think that she she might need to be
humbled something might need to occur
for her to
realize like hey
all these people all year round because
of who I am today and not who I was
three years ago
and it's just a humbling experience you
know like I just like I saw I saw she go
with the club and I was just like damn
like well that was recently yes yeah
like two days ago
like hey they keep deleting my Ig here's
10 grand go sit down like I don't want
to trust me to get miscarriage trust me
I will pay for her to sit down but
she's into the attention she likes
people walking up to her she likes the
camera she likes the attention so it's
like I can't fight with her on that you
feel me like if you get more of a
feeling of people saying hey hey then
you get off being home and and enjoying
having a home to be at and and having
you know your own and I'm not gonna
fight with you on that bro because